well what is your do you mind showing us
your bedroom i like it so far
like can you show us around a tiny bit
it looks like we're here i'm going to
turn around the camera
all right here's my dog angel grace
she's on her bed see i've got the ocean
there
and this is where my tv is and i just
want to tell you that
you know when i bought this house i was
uh getting a divorce from my first
husband
and my life i was you know
still on the show the nanny and my life
was very complicated and intense
and uh busy and i needed something that
was extremely
calming uh you know
very pristine and to make me feel
very peaceful you literally just it's
like you were in my last therapy session
i literally i not only like read i got a
new house it's
very white and clean and or it's the
same reasoning
and i also read in my office here i
looked at kevin our art department i was
like please help me make this make sense
i was like i was like i need to feel
clean
cleansed and and i just wanted to feel
happy and it does that the colors make
me feel really good
yeah me too and colors do uh influence
how you feel
yeah um and i just want to tell you that
now
that you know everything's done and
years have passed it's uh we're actually
very happily divorced i know i know i
love that the show
y'all did happily divorce you would
because he's you're actually inspired
the
show yeah and you're actually friends
with your ex right
yes yes we're the best of friends and
we're still writing partners
you know sometimes we like we marry
people because we love them
and i come from a very provincial
upbringing
it seemed like that was the next likely
step but it's not always
the right choice and when you figure
that out for yourself
you don't have to and i got this
information from a very wise old owl
and she said don't throw the baby out
with the bath water just
take what's good about it and nurture
the love
in a new way i think is probably the
healthiest if you can do it
[Music]